here backstage with the Ducks got wild
here last night in Tampa talked to a
dude that died and accidentally ended up
hitting Scientology this is awesome
thank you Tampa thank you Tampa Bay
Buccaneers go Bucks
what's up everybody down here in Tampa
getting game day ready for the live and
Alive Tour all tickets are available at
ryansickler.com about to tear up Tampa
you tickets Let's Go Go books
[Music]
[Applause]
funny show Ryan was absolutely
hysterical he's just so authentic love
the show Ryan it was fantastic love the
podcast love the Honeydew podcast so
good to see you live but I know I gotta
sign up for the patreon you sign up for
a year you get over a month
oh